hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google I work on
graphics and animation today I wanted to
talk about a way of using a class called
view property animator which was
interested in introduced in the 3.2
release and this is a way to animate
properties of views in a very easy way
it's kind of like setting the value of
one of the properties on the view but
having an animate to that value instead
of just atomically switch to it so
there's much more I could go into about
view property animator in general what
we're going to see today is an effect
where we can use view property animator
to crossfade between different images in
a picture viewer so let's take a look at
the demo so we saw another demo in a
previous episode where we used
transition drawable to do something
similar although that particular
drawable animation is about switching
just between two images this one's a
little bit more general-purpose where we
have a set of images in here that we've
loaded and we're going to crossfade as
we go between them and we'll just keep
going through the entire set of images a
little bit more general purpose so as we
click on the image we get a nice fading
effect as we go to the next image and on
and on and then we just cycle around I
only have four images loaded in here for
the purposes of this demo so pretty
pictures not terribly interesting demo
but let's take a look at the code so we
have this class called picture viewer
and in its I'm just hard coding these
I'm just loading in these small images
that I had not the way to go for a
general picture viewing application
obviously but it does for this purpose
which is to demonstrate using view
property animator and cross fading
between these things so we have two
image views that we're going to fade
between where we're going to put these
resources and we're going to first of
all set up the view property animator on
these views to have a duration of 1000
one thing to be aware of with view
property animator is the way that you
use it is by calling view animate and
that returns you a reference to the view
property animator
which all views have so they only have
that one instance inside them although
it's unique to that view so if you want
to change the precision properties on a
view property animator such as the
duration then you call dot animate and
then call the setter in this case we're
setting the duration to be a thousand I
should point out that is too long for a
general purpose UI animation but for the
purposes of actually demonstrating this
today in this video I tend to use longer
duration so you can actually see the
animation emitting on the frame rate of
the video then we create bitmap
drawables from these hard-coded images
these drawables that i defined above
nothing very interesting going on there
and then for the previous and the next
image view we populate them with the
first and second drawable there and then
when we click this is where all the
interesting stuff happens we basically
perform two animations in parallel we're
going to animate the existing image that
everybody can see out and we're going to
animate and we're going to fade the new
image the next image in and then when
it's done we're going to restore some
values and then we're going to set up
the the references to which images we're
currently showing so that we can keep
cycling through the set of images that
we have so here we're going to animate
the Alpha property which is the
translucency property of the previous
image it is currently one because that's
the image that the user is currently
seeing and we're going to add it by
animate it by saying animate which
returns this view property animator
object dot alpha zero so this is
basically saying I want you to animate
yeah I want to set the Alpha property to
zero but I want you to animate it they
are over whatever your duration is and
we're gonna call with layer and I'll
explain that in a moment this is sort of
an important element to understand for
performance tuning and then next image
view instead of fading that out like the
previous one we're gonna fade it in so
as the old one fades out we're gonna
fade the new one in so you can think of
them as sort of sitting on top of one
another where we're going to crossfade
them by fading one out and fading the
other one in it all at the same time and
then there's a new API that was added I
believe this is in jelly bean and it's
called with end action and you can mimic
this in Prior releases simply by
setting a listener on a view property
animator and doing the same exact thing
this is just a little bit more terse way
of doing that you can say when this
animation is done then I want you to
perform the following actions we're
going to update our references so that
we know which images we're actually
looking at right now and then we're
going to restore some alpha properties
so we're going to set the Alpha property
of 1 to 0 and set the other alpha
property to 1 so that they're at a good
state to animate from for the next
transition that we do now I want to get
back to this with layer thing this is
important when you're animating a
complex view or complex view hierarchy
it's important to use a layer on that
object especially if you've noticed a
framerate problem because the system
can't keep up with redrawing that thing
from scratch every time during the
animation an easy way to do that is to
set a layer type on that object so you
simply call huge set layer type and set
it to a hardware layer for example and
this API that we have here as of
jellybean the with layer API is a way
for us to do that for you so you could
do that when you run the animation you
could say set layer type on the view and
then you could put some more code in
here with your end action or you could
set a listener for the end of the
animation and then reset that layer or
remove that layer but we'll do that
automatically for you if you call the
with layer method so today's episode was
about view property animator and
specifically using view property
animator to get a very easy crossfade
operation between different
representations of views thanks